a spoiler video for star trek into
darkness it's almost the very definition
of inevitability so Big Time spoilers
here so if you haven't seen Star Trek
into darkness and you don't want it
ruined please leave I'm gonna assume
anyone who's still watching this video
has seen star trek into darkness
or doesn't care about spoilers in which
case cool so let's talk about Star Trek
into darkness had Benedict Cumberbatch
we all theorized who he could be we were
all like probably gone yeah he is caught
in the movie right when they were like
this guy's frozen he's 300 years old I
was like Botany Bay however in the Star
Trek universe there is a continuity
issue there Ricardo Montalban Spanish
dude same universe
Benedict Cumberbatch not but if we're
going on performance we could sit back
and enjoy the [ __ ] out of a movie you're
going to enjoy the [ __ ] out of this
movie because Cumberbatch kills it as
Caan I was watching the movie the second
time knowing the entire time he's
calling but he's in his cell he's all
standing there and he's all badass in
stature you're like oh yeah space seed
totally if you want to [ __ ] about his
hair length I don't know maybe Robocop
cut his hair that's a big thing I was
talking about Rose like the trailer
really doesn't show you what the movies
about doesn't really do the movie
justice do you think by watching the
trailer it's gonna be like alright cons
out there and then Jim Kirk goes after
him and then Khan intercepts him with
his big saucer section ship he's gonna
kick the [ __ ] out of Kirk and that's
that and the Enterprise nosedives of the
earth not like that at all the main bad
guy for most of the movie is Robocop
he's all I for all the enterprise Dead
or Alive you're coming with me conning
the crew the enterprise actually worked
together as a means to an end
I love how Kirk was like I'm pretty sure
we're helping him and it's true and I
love seeing that Caan is a master
tactician working with the crew the
enterprise to get what he wanted was a
very good tactic after that he didn't
need him anymore so now let's conquer
the enterprise after all no ship should
go down without a captain one of my
favorite scenes in the entire movies
when you tell Spock to lower the
shield's and sparks locked well no not
gonna do that because if you kill us and
you're gonna kill your crew he just
breaks down how he's gonna take away the
oxygen from the enterprise everyone's
going to suffocate this box like yeah
that is logical that is one smart human
being right there I must say yes Spock
did have his plan to you gotta love the
Cumberbatch eNOS I love the way
Cumberbatch delivered his lines in this
movie you're just like that that is Conn
speak right there who on earth when
Cumberbatch was delivering his Caan
lines just like I know you were like no
shall we begin even when he wasn't
speaking and he was just doing like I
see where he pushes Carol Marcus to the
ground goes over her knees up and just
steps on her leg you're like he's in it
to win it [ __ ] I love how we
got to see he was a badass in
hand-to-hand combat I always knew he was
strong you know in Wrath Akane picked up
check off like he was a Hoover vacuum or
something but it wasn't just strength in
this movie he had combat skill and you
got to see it firsthand
you know when the Klingons are throwing
down with the crew and Cumberbatch is
just wasting them with his BFG 9000 I'll
be in Cumberbatch II when I first
thought I was like something's up cuz
he's not killing Kirk in the away team
yeah he probably thought I was
threatened with missiles I imagine
that's my frozen crew I can't kill them
or I'll never get him back when he was
wasting the Klingons you got to think
yourself he's like I'm a conqueror I
like conquering challenges Klingons are
a more worthy opponent than little human
beings so yeah let's have some fun and
waste him just a side note I suppose a
cliff note in his Khan brain my only
regret is Khan didn't get to do as much
as I wanted him to do I wish we got a
movie where he was the adversary the
entire time I don't know maybe in the
third movie because he is frozen at the
end of this if you're talking about
logic it was only logical to bring Khan
into the second Star Trek movie that
Abrams is doing because Khan is the
Nemesis he's the adversary and hey Iron
Man 3 I did enjoy you too not as much as
into darkness but I still enjoyed you
this is how you do it you have a nobody
guy who reveals he's a bigger guy you
don't take a bigger guy and reveal him
to be a nobody guys see it yeah you see
it it's different
I love the parallel when Kirk had to fix
the warp core like Spock had to in Wrath
of Khan and Kirk gives his life like
Spock did you're like it was just
mind-blowing the parallel goes the
entire way man the Wrath of Khan bones
was down there was Spock Spock knocks
him out in this movie Scotty's down
there with Kirk Kirk knocks him out even
Spock is held in Scotty's like sir you
got to get down here come quick the
setting the mood the moment it was it
was very well done in the dialogue
between the two you're like - they're
all their friends and I'm sad however
then we get the uber throwback of all of
them I throw back that I liked was in
the movie but there's something about
the delivery I didn't fully accept this
when Spock it's all madmen he's all oh I
appreciated it but for some odd reason
I'm like that wasn't done as well as
Shatner did it dare I say that dare I
say that Zachary Quinto did not deliver
a line as well as Shatner day
you gotta admit you do prefer con
Shatner's not without talent like
Spock's eulogy when he's all like but my
friend I can only say this of all the
souls I have encountered his was the
moon chokes me up every time the guy
changed the pronunciation of the word
human forever for the third Star Trek JJ
Abrams is probably not going to direct
it because he's all on Star Wars now I'd
actually like to see the third Star Trek
pickup at the end of their five-year
mission and now Kirk has to give up the
captain's chair and he's all grown it's
a chair that's defined the entirety of
who he is for half a decade and maybe
you can bring Khan back for the big
Wrath of Khan thing then he can go to
city alpha 5 and city alpha 6 will
explode then you can have the movie
Wrath of Khan and I don't know maybe
everything come full circle Carol Marcus
has an accent in this movie that's
interesting because she didn't in Wrath
of Khan I don't know maybe she loses it
from being in space too long but star
trek into darkness does pull off what is
trying to do so well where I'm like
alright I'll give you a slide on the
accents in fact that Benedict
Cumberbatch is as pale white as possible
in Ricardo Montalban just is not try to
tell me he wasn't a badass in this movie
tried to tell me he wasn't a great con
the movie wrapped up a bit quickly it
was like alright we need him alive pow
darkness
Kirk wakes up oh hey you've been out for
two weeks space the final frontier
credits sounds like oh I guess it's over
at first side I felt it was a very
sudden wrap-up what I knew it was a
sudden wrap-up and I had built it in my
mind as being a very abrupt and sudden
wrap-up I watched the second time and I
was like oh it wasn't as abrupt as I
thought it was the first time in the end
star trek into darkness was badass
Khan was a badass Cumberbatch was a
badass as Khan being a badass so
Cumberbatch as Khan what did you think
of it how do you think he did whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you